cuando empezamos a estudiar álgebra
juntos empezamos a factorizar polinomios
en especial cuadra ticos por ejemplo
puedes reconocer que la expresión x
cuadrada puede escribirse como x por x
aunque una expresión polinomio como 3 x
cuadrada más 4 x en este caso ambos
términos tienen como factor común una
equis y se puede factorizar por lo tanto
puede reescribir esto como x que
multiplica a 3 x 4 y también hemos
aprendido a hacer cosas más elegantes
hemos aprendido a factorizar cosas como
x cuadrada + 7 x + 12 somos capaces de
decir oye cuáles son los dos números que
al sumar se dan 7 y es multiplicarse
entre sí dan 12 y en vídeos anteriores
mostramos porque esto funciona
bueno podemos darnos cuenta de que esos
números son 3 y 4 por lo tanto esto se
puede actualizar como x 3 que multiplica
a x + 4 y si esto no te es familiar te
encargo que revises los temas de
introducción a la factorización de
cuadráticas en khan academy hasta este
punto todo debe de ser sólo un repaso
para ti también hemos aprendido sobre la
diferencia de cuadrados por ejemplo x
cuadrada menos 9 bueno esto es x
cuadrado menos 3 al cuadrado y entonces
se puede factorizar como x + 3 por x
menos 3 y hemos visto otro tipo de
cuadráticas ahora vamos a profundizar en
el conocimiento de nuestro camino por el
álgebra vamos a desarrollar la idea de
factorizar polinomios de grado mayor de
tercer grado de cuarto grado de quinto
grado de lo que sea esto será útil en
nuestro conocimiento matemático
lo haremos pensando un poco en la
estructura en algunos de los patrones
que hemos analizado en el álgebra básica
por ejemplo imagina que vas caminando
por la calle y alguien te dice puedes
factorizar x cúbica + 7x cuadrada más 12
x bueno en un principio te darás cuenta
de que es un polinomio de tercer grado y
tal vez eso sea un poco intimidante para
ti hasta que te das cuenta de que todos
esos términos tienen como factor común a
x si la factory samos entonces obtenemos
x que multiplica a x cuadrada más 7 x +
12 y esta parte esto que tengo aquí es
lo mismo que tenemos acá arriba entonces
podemos escribirlo como x que multiplica
a x + 3 que multiplica a x + 4
podemos ver que somos capaces de
factorizar de una forma simple como esta
e incluso factorizar varias veces
también podemos analizar que la
estructura nos regresa a lo que hemos
estudiado ya en el álgebra básica así
que por ejemplo podemos ver algo como
esto de nuevo imagina que vas por la
calle y alguien te dice oye amigo
factorizar ha elevado a la cuarta
potencia más 7 a más 12 y tal vez en un
primer acercamiento digas guau tenemos
un polinomio de grado 4 cómo puedo hacer
para factorizar lo
hasta que te das cuenta que puedes
reescribir esto como a cuadrado elevado
al cuadrado más 7 a cuadrada más 12 y
ahora observa esta a cuadrada se parece
muchísimo a esta x de arriba si está
cuadrada fuera una x entonces tendríamos
x elevado al cuadrado más 7 x más 12 y
estas dos expresiones serían las mismas
así que al momento de factorizar en
lugar de poner a x al factorizar pondré
a a cuadrado así que puedo factorizar
esto utilizando que la estructura es la
misma que el polinomio de arriba y me va
a quedar como a cuadrada más 3 que
multiplica aa cuadrada más 4
ahora voy un poco rápido con todo esto
ya que este es un vídeo de introducción
un vídeo con el panorama general del
tema no te preocupes si sientes que
estoy yendo un poco rápido solo intento
darte una idea general del tema después
en el transcurso de la unidad vamos a
estudiar a profundidad cada uno de estos
casos pero para que sigas observando
hacia dónde vamos te voy a dar otro
ejemplo que también tiene como base lo
que has aprendido en tu introducción al
álgebra entonces con base la estructura
de aquí si alguien va por la calle me
parece que mucha gente camina contigo en
la calle y te dice factorizar 4x elevado
a la sexta potencia menos 9 y elevado a
la cuarta potencia bueno en un principio
parece intimidante hasta que nos damos
cuenta de que podemos escribir esto como
expresiones al cuadrado puedo escribir
esto como ok
2x elevado al cubo esto a su vez elevado
al cuadrado menos y puedo escribir este
segundo término como 3 y elevado al
cuadrado esto elevado al cuadrado y
ahora tenemos una diferencia de
cuadrados esto será 2x cúbica más 3 y
cuadrada esto que a su vez multiplica a
2 x cúbica menos 3 cuadrada en varias
ocasiones te encontrarás casos donde
tengamos que factorizar varias veces así
que veámoslo con un ejemplo imagina que
de nuevo vas caminando por la calle vaya
a parece que eres una persona muy
popular ya que otra persona te pregunta
cómo factorizar x elevado a la cuarta
menos y elevado a la cuarta bueno con
base en lo que acabamos de ver esto nos
queda como x al cuadrado elevado al
cuadrado menos 10 al cuadrado elevado al
cuadrado
bien tenemos una diferencia de cuadrados
parecida a esta otra diferencia de
cuadrados por lo tanto será la suma de x
cuadrada más de cuadrada x cuadrada más
de cuadrada que multiplica a la
diferencia entre ellos que multiplica a
x cuadrada menos de cuadrada
ahora esto es divertido porque también
es esta una diferencia de cuadrados así
que puedo reescribir esta parte como
bueno primero pondré la primera parte
que es x cuadrada malla cuadrada y ahora
podemos factorizar la segunda parte como
una diferencia de cuadrados justo como
lo hicimos acá arriba y entonces me
quedara x mas x x menos
hasta aquí lo dejaré siento que te
bombardeado con un montón de información
pero es solo el inicio no te estreses
por ello ya que analizaremos a
profundidad cada uno de estos casos y
tendrás muchas oportunidades de
practicar todo esto en khan academy para
que te sientas seguro y entiendas de
dónde sale todo esto así que vamos a
disfrutarlo